one more try santa don't throw this up
catch up jingle bells go to hell [ __ ]
get out of my way
raid for part two I'm having enough
trouble staying upright as it is OOP
nailed it
[Laughter]
I'm begin when ready I'm ready right now
come on kid oh this is not good why does
everybody hate you kids
[Music]
ah he almost made it I love me some poon
here we go winner I want anyway no all
the blood and dismembered body parts I
won y'all saw all right take 2:30
[Applause]
Smith me ow my head hole I'm gonna make
this slender okay I'm not scared I'm not
scared at all
Oh
Wow Oh God Oh No okay yeah you both die
Oh Roman rope swing I don't think I'm
good at rope swings Oh oh god no
okay
oh no no do much and we're good Oh epic
Oh fist me what oh good I hear something
I guess it was nothing
I got a block it with my 7 but Jillian
tries let me grab it why oh I tried
grabbing on to the axe that didn't help
my situation at all you took out my
helmet excuse me oh hi buddy
y'alright son good
Drock got it drop no girl on at No okay
now I just need to swing over to the
stealthy like good thing I've got those
helmet oh they have noticed me yet as
long as I don't scream in pain hey this
has been happy wheels highlights thanks
for watching if you like what you saw
and you want to see more why not
subscribe to my channel and if you had a
favorite moment in the video let me know
in the comments below thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye